[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of erisa fury i'm kelsey cook and today
I'm very excited I'm joined by the
incredible chef dad thank you thanks for
having me I love what you've done with
the place
thank you so much my living room it's
very nice casual rewards all my trophies
looks like something bill burr would
design yeah I know so weird so I'm very
excited to play you because you actually
have a foosball table in your apartment
this exact foosball table the warrior or
a shout out to warrior future the
beautiful table you are the second
person we've had on who has the table so
this is kind of it's like a new thing
well here's the truth
I wanted a pool table but it wouldn't
fit the space so it's like well maybe
I'll get a foosball table I didn't
realize how bad and unenjoyable foosball
is get the [ __ ] out it's really not
we're done it's really not that fun for
me I'm here because I love you and I
love comedy but this game is like it's
noisy I'm not very good at it it's hard
to go oh stop doing Spinneys don't spin
these are fun you are seriously at 7
years old and then it hits the thing
allowed Jeff died hashtags if any other
fun all right so no spinning today no
spinning today it should be noted before
we start you come to my house right well
I'm like big wrestling parties a little
pro wrestling and then you come over and
you just go up they won't want to play
foosball
yeah she seems sweet and I love foosball
this will be good and then you go back
and it's like over and my friends look
humiliated I mean you giggle like
usually if you're gonna play like
someone at basketball right you like
let's say LeBron James like else he
won't play basketball yeah he'd go a
little easy on you not you if you were
LeBron Anessa no you just be like Duncan
likes walking the shots and be like it's
a little you can take it easy on people
you know let them learn Fu's I don't
know I can't stop this is the one yeah
there's something it's in my DNA it's my
parents and that plan first of all it's
the reason I exist and so it's like I
can't I don't know how to it's the
reason you
it's the reason I exist I wouldn't exist
without this isn't that crazy yeah cuz
then they would have never met yeah and
then they wouldn't have hooked up no
yeah how did it work where they add a
foosball tournament and they're like
they just like man you get your wrist
shows look at those wrists yeah those
golden wrists the other thing I'm sure I
don't know but that's why this is so fun
for I mean you brought a basketball I'll
never be tall enough to dunk or anything
cool like that again in volleyball as a
setter I was never the hitter so
foosball is my that's my dunk right it's
that sound which is like I should have a
podcast where it's just I have guests
who clearly can't dunk and then I just
keep dunking on them and then going R it
every time I dunk on you you have to eat
a turd brownie up every time I dug you
have to feel like you know I should you
should have to do some [ __ ] of high
score but you won't score that's the
broad I put on this yellow dot right I
mean you can therefore but you can you
can do that that's not what they're no
it's just separating words oh yeah
but I've been lying to everyone of my
houseguests I believe you hear a man
with a foosball table seem like you know
it Jesus Christ
Johnny trees they went round [ __ ] it
wasn't a very neighborly thing to do
even hit my goalie you'd never see that
in soccer where the ball hits him and he
just falls off he just goes completely
upside down and that goes matrix's okay
good that's pretty good you even said
before we started I'm not gonna score
and that wasn't very pretty but I'll
take it
you don't hit the ball hard okay take a
point take a point yeah I forgot about
the little beads all right I don't like
getting even one point all right you
ready yeah I'm so nervous I shouldn't be
this nervous
that's the noise I was telling you about
earlier yeah so no one's beat you yet
right no Steve Rannazzisi beat me in the
second game because he could score on
either goal and I was playing with my
arms crossed so that's that seems too
pretty but other than that no nobody's
beat me like in a clean j-diddy
get that I don't get a close-up on that
rose and j-diddy
yeah yeah kid you know when I got that
nickname nobody gave you that nickname
of you for sure gave yourself up next to
name 106 the name of the guy that gave
me that nickname
that's my instinct Jesus you've scored
too that's unsettling well this is just
a friendly game five won't break your
finger I'm not even the dumbest thing
someone's done on the show yeah I will
for sure if you think I won't break your
fingers yeah well we're not a Purvis but
you would accidentally no I would do it
on purpose is that the game that's the
game [ __ ]
sorry for interrupting guys I just want
to take a quick second to say thank you
to my bookie for sponsoring this episode
of wrists of fury you know we love
making bets here on our superior and I
know I'm super excited to make more bets
on my Seahawks it's a new season Antonio
Brown moved teams again Le'Veon Bell as
far as we know it's still with the Jets
Odell Beckham I think people in playing
with a two million dollar watch on his
wrist did you know that my bookie is the
best place to bet on football every
weekend my bookie has great bonuses and
some of the best prospects this year
they're hosting the first online
handicapping super
first place is guaranteed to win at
least $100,000 and it only costs $100
then all you got to do is pick five + FL
games against the spread every week
finally don't ward and score your share
of the huge cash prize pool
my bookie has live in game betting on
every NFL game they've got an insane
amount of player perks and if you love
fantasy sports you can even buy the
over/under on how many fantasy points a
player will score each game for our fans
my bookie is offering double your purse
deposit up to $1,000 by using the code
wrist
that's my Bao kie and don't forget to
use the promo code wrists creating your
account to get the bonus thanks again
for watching and make sure to hit that
subscribe button to watch more recipe
now back to the UPS round
- so come over here so we're gonna play
the second round now okay where we make
it easier for you to beat me but he has
my lucky number five five okay alright
hi everyone
okay so you got number five so that
means every time you score it counts for
two points so in a game to five you
basically just have to get three and
you'd beat me right my handicap here I
think that bad my handicap is that our
director is gonna it's like directors
choice he's gonna shout out a different
punishment that I have to do every point
oh so you know something oppression it's
only your guest has to do punishments no
you get an advantage that's great and I
get a punishment so which makes me
nervous because you are who you already
scored two of me the first okay I gotta
focus the secret is to score right away
get that first one yeah is that big in
the tournaments and stuff yeah yeah
because the games are so I mean it's
only two five so you scoring that first
one actually doesn't make a really big
difference okay so what's my first
punishment cross-arm okay oh sorry okay
okay so look whisk your biscuits just
controlling the pregame Jeff does [ __ ]
talk
so Jesus Christ this feels good that's
too right yeah [ __ ] mmm I feel anxious I
don't like this feeling okay what's my
next punishment damn it Bryan well what
do you want him to say uh-oh just use
your
what is he supposed to do what's a
punishment that you'd be fine with oh
that didn't work it's dubbed another one
damn it it's all I need is one more we
have this in the bag here okay what's
your mouth just deep throat damn it
that's what we should do it'd be really
one of these radians to go up I'm a
pirate oh this is a shot what was who
one leg in an eyepatch right one leg one
arm talk like a pirate that's a fun one
all right go matey maybe that is the
ball game and can we also is it the
first shut up has there ever been a
shadow no no there has not I think I
mean maybe it's too soon but actually I
feel so upset all right what do we do it
now we're good friends
this is upsetting I'm just really still
like reeling from that lots of it okay
you had to do pirate things and cross
arms you can always say that so yeah
Jeff beat me when I had to do a bunch of
[ __ ] yeah I mean you didn't beat but
the fact that was a shutout that's
upsetting okay so now we play two ball
and winner-takes-all so technically it's
one to one right now so this game
matters has this ever gone like seven
hours this sounds hard is it no I mean
it goes pretty fast and now that I have
normal access I'll probably be running
yeah god bless it Godspeed
so if you lose I texted our friend Adam
ray yeah Adam knows you well and I was
like what would be a good punishment for
a Jeff just to humiliate him just to
really like raise the stakes and he's
like Jeff is a notoriously bad speller
yes so if you lose yeah I didn't
graduate high school that doesn't shock
me and I've nominated it
I just don't hey hey how do you spell a
secret oh my god this is gonna be good
then I I have to meet you because I have
to hear this so we're gonna have a
spelling bee if you lose I'm sweating
just yeah yeah we're gonna have a
spelling bee if you lose so get ready
one two three go no I feel so
uncoordinated plain tube all right all
right
that kind of hurts cuz that's too you
know yeah yeah hey when is just I know
it's fun all right
yeah she make us up oh hold on you have
to do the countdown it really is and
you're like you cannot you cannot help
yourself
it's good what are you eating
oh you were for sure the guy that would
piss me off where I would do all the
studying and then just like close the
expert check you like well that's a good
thing about having lots of friends
people like I will help Jeff he's an
idiot thanks guys cheater
1 2 3 go
that we went in yeah come on Fuji lose
it that's a more cute way to say food
economy way plane to gonna do but see
that's the shot you that was nice that
was nice
I'll give you that thank you golly did
that funny thing we talked about I know
one two three go that is a we're gonna
pick a clip one two three go
[Applause]
jeepers okay ready one two three
no [ __ ] way are you serious okay
wrists of fury nickname yep one time can
we talk about so you actually believe
that Bigfoots real yeah well it's not
actually that crazy to believe oh my god
you what do you know about her rash
people that he is not real do you still
believe in Santa
no it's not the same is pretty much it
but I think people that don't believe in
Bigfoot just ain't done no homework like
the okay hold on the guy who's making
the claim that Bigfoot is real just said
ain't done no home yeah
Bigfoot's it has nothing new with
English one two three go
how'd that D ready this time it didn't
really work a shoot well that's cuz I
mean that's strong generally if it's if
it's gonna be like a tap or something
yeah one two three go
shei shot you do hits I will say your
maybe top two people we've got on that
hit the ball as hard as you do
really yeah you got it you do have a
good shot have you had Mitch Berlin he's
very good right uh he is pretty good I
played him before it but now he peppers
it in that thing that's a wash right no
that's a wash because I scored one you
squawk oh you're right I'm sorry
yeah yeah we got to get on all things
comedy referee in here you see that did
you know cheating
she's also capable of cheating too good
yes I got that one this episode's
running long you got a point okay one
two three
are you see this you were like is this
game gonna go till like 4:00 in the
morning no no it actually is okay ready
Oh see that strategy did you just not
hit it no no I I just went to block
yours out instead of playing for mine no
[Applause]
she yet alright get out an environment
yeah kind of ground your plant or pet
the plants like a baby Squatch oh my god
you I can't believe you say this so
publicly Oh get ready to spell a [ __ ]
[Applause]
I am so sweaty your hair [ __ ] this is
what I don't write with your bears oh my
god what'd you do Sega minute you shut
it out so why don't we want to do that
to make up for losing a lot of drama
there were a lot of draws on this one
yeah oh my god okay so that really is
the worst part of [ __ ] bipedal in
hominid nothing will be worse than you
believe in a Bigfoot I promise you that
okay if you lose the spelling bee right
you gotta get a dog treat you got it if
you can correctly spell all three of
these words you already got the words I
do have the words big Moe if you can
smell all three words right then you get
to say that you beat me okay but I
didn't but you just so I can cheat life
you can cheat like this I can do that
anyways I have access to dishonesty I
get that you go to Kelsey Cook thing
yeah whipped her ass attacked like what
she's really good yeah it was easy for
me though I'm a guy yeah that would be
alive my words right now
you're the worst that would be the lot
you're the worst
we're number one handkerchief oh okay
I know these you blow your nose in them
can use the word in a sentence I I came
into the handkerchief inappropriate yeah
we're never does it makes it sound like
you're like yeah yeah I'm about to know
it's like for jerking off really way
more like it's so pranking Jeff is so
proper and coming is so like primitive
you know she's a gamma what do you want
to go you lay it out like a picnic cloth
okay I hope by the way that that's how
you come no I come like this H a and K
wrong already
oh I keep going ER CH e I have so wrong
D so put a little easy on the end and
you go why is that word there so it's a
J and D keer that's ridiculous eh i EF
not yeah a DS silent why would they make
that in there
cuz cuz words man I don't know that's
the problem with learning how to spell
is that nothing makes sense
you think you learn a rule like Oh see
cut sound and then like well what's this
K about look at that also does a cuss
out I think it was seized already doing
that job I don't understand and then my
tutor at age 22 is like just can you try
and [ __ ] put this together
yeah argue your way out of learning how
to spell you alone I'm not gonna change
the right like I'm gonna he's got a
point
let's get rid of a letter that's been
around yeah let's throw it all the [ __ ]
out my handkerchief next word is Colonel
I then you know in the military is this
one is expelled colonial or whatever I
don't know you tell me this is the part
of the show where I try to get the
cameraman and producers to help me cheat
do not help him in any way favorite
words I'm looking at all of you see did
somebody get them no no no pic just
picture one is that word just I pray
that we have a graphic oh my god
it's thank you very so of its on some
offenses it so up see Oh lol let me look
at it
no because the other words on there I'll
show you their strategy
Oh Jeff God that was so funny if you're
cheating you ain't trying right my dad
used to say that my mom would get so
husband of the air yeah real bad guy oh
all right this is it Jeff
okay last word Chihuahua oh yeah I love
those it's hard to spell I bet Chihuahua
si nailed it buddy
um sounded ouch there we go
ah okay you a you a chihuahua no but you
were actually very close no actually I'm
surprised at how close you were you just
missed an H you almost put my reputation
on the line
Oh oh I didn't reach boy right I'm not
even good at ooh my gosh cuz he was
spotted I got oh geez someone's helping
me see and then I looked up here to try
to act like I was thinking in a thought
a place you'd look when you're thinking
I still screwed dad to me it didn't work
it wasn't success just so you know both
of you thank you that's the nicest thing
someone's done for me all day well you
know what that means
that means I get to eat a dog biscuit no
phone time I don't know maybe you will
also enjoy them I'm real fussy eater oh
then just like a little kid thing you
want like chicken strips or like a
little mini pizza with cheese or
something I don't eat a lot of things
yeah you're a I think people believe I
eat these I think people picture me in
my apartment going I bet that Jeff does
just sitting there I know I do
eatin milk-bones I for sure picture you
doing that all right
do a few dull thing yes oh okay
smells like like a cracker yeah it kind
of tastes like a wheat pen oh well all
right
wait so here's a question for you Bob
Stalin
a good question do you think you eat
half do it no that was not that bad or I
hated that well I don't do a whole thing
so it is just over by the time yeah I
think you should do the whole thing okay
oh god I've never disagreed with dogs
before I also like licking my castle Oh
[Laughter]
God you have a PA that can bring me like
a trash can in something I won't spit it
out but we might be puking
someone grab me the trash can keep
chewing keep eating
thank you Jeff nice to meet you
I normally don't just puke all the time
does it taste like anything you've ever
had before it no no no I think maybe
when I talk I'm breathing that in like
when I breathe in it like gives me the
whiff of why are we going oh my god
don't you don't you just swallow it
swallow it chase them with water yeah
you did it you did it
oh man still not as bad as the spelling
okay I think I'm out of the one I think
I'm at other ones here yeah yeah whoo
Wow
chant oh yeah pukey is the worst feeling
in the world
ya know well later we'll go are they
mine I'm fine
plug where people can find you uh at je
FF d ye on everything and then I also
have a podcast on this on all things
comedy called Jeff dies friendship
podcast where I have people come on that
are either my friends or willing to be
my friends that's the rule that's nice
that's very nice yeah I got good friends
Kelsey cooks gonna be on it I would love
that catch me on it you can follow me on
instagram at Kelsey cook comedy
Twitter's that Kelsey cook Kelsey cook
calm for tour dates please go listen to
the self helpless podcast and also
subscribe to the all things comedy
youtube channel go check out the other
episodes of Rissa theory thank you so
much for ever
yes thanks for watching you guys we'll
see you next time bye thank you guys for
watching another episode of erisa fury
be sure to pick up your official wrist
of Fury shirts they are buttery soft
they feel like dolphin skin there's
lovely be sure to LIKE and subscribe to
the all things comedy channel and you
can get the shirts at the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you